the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we begin our study of integral
calculus which had its roots back in
ancient Greece roughly 600 BC and began
with an investigation of a study of area
in a certain manner of speaking today's
lecture could be called calculus
revisited revisited in the sense that
integral calculus can be studied quite
apart from the fact that differential
calculus was ever invented
we'll see later in this block of
material that there is a wondrous
relationship between integral and
differential calculus but perhaps the
best proof that integral calculus can be
studied independently of differential
calculus lies in the fact that the
ancient Greek was doing integral
calculus in 600 BC whereas differential
calculus did not begin until about 1680
AD with Sir Isaac Newton well at any
rate then what we'll call today's
lecture is simply two-dimensional area
in other words this is how the subject
began with studying the amount of space
in plane regions two-dimensional area as
opposed to say as we'll talk about later
three dimensional area which is really a
fancy word for volume etc but enough
about that for the time being
two-dimensional area or calculus
revisited revisited and to see what's
happening over here the study of area
was the forerunner of integral calculus
as we now know it it began in ancient
Greece roughly 600 BC the branch of
calculus that we've been studying up
until now in our course differential
calculus did not begin until 1680 ad
notice then the interesting
juxtaposition in time in other words
pedagogically one seems to study
differential calculus before integral
calculus chronologically integral
calculus preceded differential calculus
by more than 2,000 years now this is a
rather beautiful study it's one of the
most aesthetic parts of elementary
mathematics namely the simplicity with
which the Greek was able to tackle the
sophisticated problem of finding areas
in general
started with three basically simple
properties of area so simple that most
of us are willing to accept them almost
intuitively we'll call these the axioms
for area and simply stated they were the
following one that the area of a
rectangle is the base times the height -
if one region is contained within
another we can take the area of the
contained region is less than or equal
to in other words can be no greater than
that of the containing region roughly
speaking the small of the region the
smaller its area and finally written
slightly more formally here the old high
school axiom for plain geometry that the
area of the whole equals a sum of the
areas of the parts that if a region R is
subdivided into a union of mutually
exclusive pieces then the area of the
entire region is equal to the sum of the
areas of the constituent parts and with
just these three axioms the ancient
Greek invented a technique for finding
areas that today is still known by its
original name the method of exhaustion
and here exhaustion does not refer to
the fact that we get tired using the
system even though as we shall soon see
it's quite intricate it refers to the
fact that we take the region whose area
we want to find and exhaust the space by
squeezing it between regions which are
made up of rectangles stated more
precisely given a region R and I'll
define this more precisely later we
squeeze it between two networks of
rectangles the idea being what that we
know what the area of a rectangle is and
consequently by the fact that the area
of the whole equals the sum of the areas
of the parts if we have a rectangular
Network knowing how to find the area of
each rectangle we know how to find the
area of the rectangular Network now
rather than to wax on like this
philosophically let's tackle a specific
problem in fact give or take a little
bit this is specifically the problem
that Archimedes dealt with in finding
the area of parabolic segments way back
as I say in the
300 to 600 BC era as an example consider
the following we wish to determine the
area of the region are a sub R where the
region R is that region which is bounded
above by the curve y equals x squared
below by the x-axis on the left by the y
axis and on the right by the line x
equals 1 in other words this region in
here now here's the way we put the
squeeze on and we'll start this quite
gradually the first thing that we
observe is that if we draw a line
parallel to the x axis through the point
1 comma 1 the highest point of our
region here we've construct a rectangle
which contains our region R and since R
is contained in the rectangle the area
of the region R must be less than the
area of the rectangle but notice that
this particular rectangle that we've
just constructed has its base equal to 1
its height equal to 1 therefore by our
first axiom it's area is 1 times 1 or 1
also since intuitively area is a
positive thing we see just from this
quick diagram that whatever the area of
the region is we now have it bounded
between 0 & 1 we have an upper bound we
have a lower bound we have this thing
cop ok now there's still a lot of space
between 0 & 1 the method of exhaustion
refines this idea namely what we do next
is we say look at instead of just
drawing one big rectangle like this
why don't we partition the base of our
region R into two equal parts in other
words let's locate the point one half
which of course is midway between 0 & 1
now what I can do is I can circumscribe
two rectangles one of which is the
rectangle whose height corresponds to
the x coordinate equal in 1/2 that means
the y coordinate is 1/4 and the second
rectangle the one whose x coordinate the
x coordinate of the height is 1 and
since y equals x squared the height is
also 1 you see notice that by picking a
region which is a curve which is always
rising then
point of each region is the point that's
farthest to the left and the highest
point of each region is the point that's
furthest to the right and keeping this
in mind you see by making rectangles
corresponding to the points furthest to
the right in each interval I get a
rectangle which contains the portion of
the region Islands I'm talking about in
other words if I look at this
rectangular Network my region R is
contained inside that consequently it's
area is less than the area of the
rectangular Network now what is the area
of this rectangular Network well the big
rectangle has its base equal to 1/2 and
it's height equal to 1 so it's area as
1/2 the small rectangle has its base
equal to 1/2 and its height equal to 1/4
since its area is the base times the
height its area is 1/8 1/8 plus 1/2 is
5/8 in other words the area of the
rectangular network which contains R is
5/8 consequently the area of the region
R must be less than 5/8 on the other
hand notice that the lowest point in the
second and the Vote corresponds to X
equaling 1/2 in other words notice that
this particular rectangle whose base is
1/2 and whose height is 1/4 that this
rectangle here is inscribed in the
region R it's area is 1/8 and since it's
contained within the region R its area
must be less than the area of the region
R and so we're now certain that whatever
the area of the region R is it's between
1/8 and 5/8 and by the way notice in
terms of these shaded regions that even
though this is an approximation which is
too large to be the right answer it is
closer to being the right answer than
this approximation here in other words
notice that the difference between the
over estimate here and the over estimate
here is this amount in here you see
we've chopped off part of the error but
we'll talk about that as I say in more
detail in the notes what I'd like to do
is to give you an overall view of what's
happening over here you see to
generalize the method of exhaustion we
do what the mathematician usually does
instead of saying let's divide the base
of the region into two equal parts or
three equal parts or four equal parts
we say let's divide it into n equal
parts now if we divide the space into n
equal parts since the whole region the
whole length is 0 to 1 divided into n
equal parts means that my points of
division will be 1 over N 2 over N 3
over n etc right down to n over N which
is 1 what I do now is I pick the left
the right endpoint of each point in that
partition to draw my rectangle you see
each of these rectangles that I draw
this way contains the corresponding part
of my region R consequently the area of
this rectangular network must be an
upper bound for the area of my region R
now because it's going to be an upper
bound and because it depends on what the
value of n is I will denote that upper
bound by u sub N and what will u sub n
be it's the sum of the areas of these
circumscribed rectangles and it's not
difficult to see from this picture
let's take a look that since this
rectangle has its height corresponding
to the x-coordinate equaling 1 over N
and since the y-coordinate is the square
of the x-coordinate the height of this
rectangle will be 1 over N squared the
base is 1 over n so the area of that
circumscribed rectangle is 1 over N
squared times 1 over n similarly the
next rectangle here has its height
corresponding to the x-coordinate 2 over
n so its height is 2 over N squared keep
in mind the y-coordinate is a square of
the x-coordinate here the base of all of
these rectangles is 1 over N and
proceeding in this way I finally come
down to the last rectangle whose height
is what well the x-coordinate is 1 so
the y-coordinate is 1 to keep my form
here I'll write that as n over N its
height is therefore n over m squared the
base of that rectangle is 1 over N so
the area of that last rectangle is n
over N squared times 1 over n now you
see that's what that's an area which is
too large to be a sub R well let's take
a look now and see what's happening here
notice that each of these terms
has an N cubed in the denominator so I
can factor out the n cubed term and what
I'm left with is what the sum of the
first n squares 1 squared plus 2 squared
plus 3 squared etc plus etc and squid in
other words this tells me how to find U
sub n for any value of n and we'll talk
about that some more in a little while
that's an upper bound in a corresponding
way I can also find a lower bound namely
what I'll do now is pick the smallest
rectangle in each region in other words
I'll now inscribe rectangles inside my
region R and therefore find a
rectangular region whose area is less
than that of the region R and to do that
without going through the details notice
that essentially all I have to do is
shift each of these rectangles over by
one partition namely notice for example
that the lower the smallest height in
the second partition here is the one
which corresponds to the height one over
N in other words what I do now is to
inscribe the rectangles I just shift
everything over like this and leaving
the details out and letting you verify
these for yourselves
I can again mimic exactly what I did
before the only difference being now
that is that instead of the height of
the last rectangle being n over N notice
that it's n minus r n n minus 1 over N
squared in other words the x-coordinate
is n minus 1 over n the y-coordinate is
the square of the x-coordinate in other
words notice that this point here gives
rise to the height of the lowest
rectangle that can be inscribed in my
last portion here so without further ado
it turns out that else sub n the lower
estimate is 1 over n cubed times the sum
of the first n minus 1 squares okay now
let's keep track of just one of these
that we've done over here so far what
we've done is what for each n we have
squeezed a sub R between two numbers one
number being an upper approximation one
number being a lower proximation now
notice that the use of N and the L sub n
are functions of n a sub R is a constant
that's the area of the region R
what the method of exhaustion means is
simply this we say look at let's take
the limit of the L sub n as n approaches
infinity and let's take the limit of the
u sub n as n approaches infinity
observing that for each n a sub R is
squeezed between these two consequently
since a sub R is squeezed between these
two for each end
it must be squeezed between these two
when we go to the limit in other words
whatever a sub R is it must be between
these two limits now here's the key step
it turns out at least in this particular
problem that the limit of L sub n as n
goes to infinity is the same as the
limit of u sub n as n goes to infinity
and the best way to see that without
becoming too fancy at this stage of the
game is to observe that the diff for a
given n the difference between u sub N
and L sub n is just 1 over n and again
I'll just indicate to you from this
diagram how we can see that notice that
back here the way we went from u sub n
to L sub n was we just pushed over this
whole network by one unit in other words
the rectangle that we squeezed out in
going from the upper sum to the lower
sum was just this particular rectangle
whose height was 1 and whose base was 1
over N in other words the area that
we've kicked out in going from L sub n
to u sub n is 1 over n this is what this
thing here says over here this is worked
out in detail in the notes but again I
just want to go through this thing
quickly so we get the idea of what's
happening over here in other words since
u sub n minus L sub n is 1 over N that's
just another way of saying what that the
limit of this difference is just the
limit of 1 over N as n goes to infinity
but that's clearly 0 in other words
these two limits are the same because
their difference goes to 0 in the limit
consequently since these two things are
the same and a sub r is caught between
these two it must be that a sub R is
equal to this common limit and that's
precisely what the method of exhaustion
was we squeezed what we were looking for
between two estimates which converge
towards each other as ended lives now by
the way I'm going to point out the fact
it's very very difficult in general to
find what this limit is we're going to
see that in working a few specific
problems well I thought might be
informative without going through the
details right now I have taken the
liberty of computing L sub n and u sub n
in this problem for N equals a thousand
in other words if we divided this region
into a thousand equal parts and took the
network of circumscribed rectangles and
inscribed rectangles it would turn out
that the area of the inscribed
rectangles would be zero point three
three two eight three three five and for
the circumscribed rectangles zero point
three three three eight three three five
and by the way notice how this is borne
out notice that the difference between
these two is precisely one one
thousandth and that is one over n with n
equal to a thousand but that's not the
important point here the important point
is is that just looking at this decimal
expansion if I didn't know anything else
I know that a sub R is caught between
these two consequently to two decimal
places I can be sure that H sub R is
0.33 and notice that if I want more and
more decimal place accuracy especially
if I have access to a desk calculator I
don't really have to compute the limit
exactly I can feed the formula into the
Machine and put the squeeze on and get
as many decimal place accuracy as I want
by the way as an aside this is exactly
what we did in high school when we said
things like let PI equal twenty two
sevenths pi is not equal to 23 sevenths
among other things 22 sevenths is a
rational number it's the ratio of two
whole numbers pi is an irrational number
what people really meant was that you
can't tell the difference between PI and
22 sevenths to two decimal places they
both begin 3.14 and consequently if all
you've wanted to measure what's the two
decimal digits you could use 22 sevenths
as the approximation for pi but if you
wanted to squeeze out more places you'd
have to use a more refined approach by
the way let me point out that one of the
reasons I chose the curve y equals x
squared to work with was
you may recall that back in our
discussion of mathematical induction one
of the problems that we worked on was to
show how we find by induction the recipe
for the sum of the first n squares and
by way of review let me recall for you
the fact that the sum of the first n
squares was given by n times n plus 1
times 2n plus 1 over 6 ok in other words
going back to our recipe for you sir
then I can now replace 1 squared plus 2
squared plus etc N squared by n times n
plus 1 times 2n plus 1 over 6 and if I
now divide through by n cubed
judiciously namely cancelling out one
end with this end dividing n plus 1 by N
and 2n plus 1 by n I get that u sub n is
1/6 n plus 1 over n times 2n plus 1 over
N and that can be written even more
suggestively as 1/6 times 1 plus 1 over
n times 2 plus 1 over n and I can now
put a very nice mathematical
interpretation on this namely notice
that no matter how big n is 1 plus 1
over N is bigger than 1 you see because
1 over N is positive and 2 plus 1 over N
is bigger than 2 consequently whatever
this is it's bigger than 1/6 times 1
times 2 which is 1/3 in other words for
each n u sub n is greater than 1/3 it
also happens that as n gets larger u sub
n gets smaller again looking at this
recipe the bigger n is the bigger is our
denominator and the bigger the
denominator the smaller the fraction and
finally notice that as n goes to
infinity U sub n gets arbitrarily close
to 1/3 in value because 1 over n
approaches 0 in the limit in fact it is
0 in the limit so summarizing then each
u sub n is bigger than 1/3 as n
increases u sub n decreases and the
limit of u sub n as n approaches
infinity is 1/3 pictorially what this
means is that if we locate 1/3 on a
number line
the use of ends converge uniformly in
the sense of moving steadily towards the
left towards one third as the limit well
that's an upper squeeze the lower
squeeze comes from the fact that in a
similar way we can show that L sub n is
1/6 and look at how close this comes to
parallel in the structure of U sub N 1
minus 1 over N times 2 minus 1 over n
minus is here instead of pluses as we
had above now mimicking what we did
before notice now that for each n since
we're subtracting over here for each n L
sub n is less than 1/3 but now since the
fractions get smaller as n gets bigger
and you're subtracting them the
difference becomes larger in other words
now notice that each L sub n is less
than 1/3 as n increases L sub n
increases and the limit of L sub n as n
approaches infinity is also 1/3 in other
words if we draw this in back here look
what the L sub ends are doing there are
less than 1/3 but they move steadily
towards the right as n increases pushing
in on 1/3 and since a sub R is always
caught between these two and these two
converges relentlessly upon 1/3 it must
be by definition if there is an area at
all that the area of the region R must
be exactly 1/3 and by the way just as a
quick aside notice how important it is
that we not only have upper and lower
bounds which converged they must
converge to the same value in other
words what I'm saying is suppose all the
use of ends get arbitrarily close to
what I call script L sub 1 and all the L
sub ends get arbitrarily close to L 2
over here then all I'm saying is all we
would know is that the area was
someplace between l2 and l1 we couldn't
conclude that it was exactly equal to
1/3 you see the method of exhaustion
implies that all the error all the room
for doubt is squeezed out by the way
there was nothing sacred about choosing
y equals x squared we could generalize
this and I'm going to do this kind of
rapidly because I just want you to hear
what I'm saying
this is all written out in great detail
in our supplementary notes the idea is
this let F be any positive continuous
function on a B and non-decreasing the
non decreasing part is just for the
convenience of being able to locate the
high and low points of each partition
point conveniently partition a B into n
equal parts calling the first partition
point x sub 0 the last partition points
X sub N and the points in between x1 up
to X n minus 1 in other words we
partition this closed interval into n
equal parts and what we can now do is
what pick the lowest point in each
region the highest point in each region
to form a rectangle we can form U sub N
and L sub N and you see just what see
the L sub n you just pick this height
which is f of X sub 0 f of a the height
the base is Delta X you just add these
all up until you get to your last
inscribed partition point that's X sub n
minus 1 okay
u sub n is the same thing only now your
first rectangle has its height
corresponding to x equals x1
consequently the height is f of x1 the
base is Delta X where in each of these
Delta X is just what this total length
which is B minus a divided into n equal
parts and to review the so-called Sigma
notation that we have in our course of
in the section in the textbook and we'll
have exercises on this to make sure that
you are familiar with this notation the
shortcut notation for writing this sum
is given by this we add up f of X sub K
times Delta X as a subscript K is
allowed to vary from 1 to N and here we
form the same sub sum only now the
subscript K varies from 0 to n minus 1
and any rate the observations are this
that u sub N and L sub n converge to the
same limit in fact this isn't too hard
to show if you just algebraically
subtract
else they blend from you sir then notice
that the only terms that won't cancel
are the last term here see f of X sub n
times Delta X has no counterpart here
because this ends with the subscript n
minus 1 similarly there is no zero
subscript in U sub n so this term won't
cancel to make a long story short if we
just subtract L sub n from u sub n that
difference will be f of X sub n times
Delta X minus f of X sub 0 times Delta X
see that's just this difference over
here Delta X is B minus a over N X sub n
was called B X sub 0 was called a in
other words the difference between u sub
N and L sub n is just F of B minus F of
a times B minus a over N and the
important thing to observe is that a B F
of a and F of B are fixed constants the
only thing that depends on n is this
denominator consequently as n goes to
infinity since the rest of this thing is
a constant the whole term goes to 0 in
other words the difference between UN
and L n goes to 0 in the limit that
means that the limit of u sub n as n
approaches infinity equals the limit of
use L sub n as n approaches infinity a
sub R is always clocked between L sub N
and use of n by this very construction
consequently what this means is that the
area of the region R must equal this
common limit ok now by the way this
looks very hard and it is difficult in
fact in general these limits are very
hard to find the point that I thought
would be interesting to mention at this
stage of the game is that if all we want
is an estimate for the area under the
curve there are faster and better ways
of doing this you see the beauty of this
technique here is that it's a technique
for exhausting the space completely we
find exact areas this way let me give
you a for instance here namely let me
explain to you what we mean by
trapezoidal approximation z' let's take
the same region y equals x squared and
now will the value of the two parts here
and what we'll do is we replace the the
arc of the curve by the straight-line
segment the court that joins two points
here in other words using the accented
shock here to illustrate this what I'm
going to do is instead of finding the
area of the region R I'm going to find
the area of the region which has the top
of our replaced by these two live
segments all I want you to observe is
that this first region here is a
triangle whose height is 1/4 and whose
base is a half consequently its area of
being 1/2 the base times the height is
1/16 the second region here is a
trapezoid whose bases are 1 and 1/4 and
whose height is 1/2 and since the area
of a trapezoid is 1/2 the sum of the
bases times the height we get that the
area of this trapezoid is 5/16 therefore
the area of the triangle plus the
trapezoid is 616 or 3/8 which is 0.375
recall that one-third we've just seen
was the exact answer and notice how
close this approximation is to the exact
answer even with just two subdivisions
over here in fact sparing you the
details if you now divide the base here
into four equal parts thus forming your
trapezoidal approximation is
corresponding to what altitudes of 1/16
1/4 9/16 and 1 and adding up the areas
of all these trapezoids by the way this
is a bit unfortunate this is a triangle
but we can view a triangle as being a
degenerate trapezoid meaning the height
here just happens to be 0 at this
particular point but let's not worry
about that let's just get the idea of
what the trapezoidal approximation idea
means we find the area of these four
trapezoids and we use that as an
approximation for the area under the
curve by the way just coming back here
for a moment notice that because this
curve is always holding water the court
will always lie above the arc and
consequently not only do we get
approximation using trapezoids this way
that's reasonably close but we also know
by the geometry here that our
approximation must be too large to be
the right answer in other words we're
going to get an over approximation but
watch how close we come leaving these
details for you to verify all I show
here is that if you add up the areas of
these four regions we wind up with 44
over 128 which is eleven thirty seconds
and eleven thirty seconds is mighty
close to one third being what eleven
thirty thirds now let's look at how
close with just four subdivisions we get
to an approximation that's good for the
area under the curve without having to
put the squeeze on but to get the exact
area we need the squeeze we have to push
the thing from above from below and show
that these two things that were
squeezing it between as gruesome as it
sounds converge towards each other the
thing that we're looking for is caught
between them and consequently must be
the common limit that was the method of
exhaustion as known by the ancient
Greeks and if this seems tough to you
think of it from two points of view one
it is tough and secondly if people of
some 2,500 years ago were able to do
this it should be at least plausible
that with a little bit of effort we can
get a good feeling for what's going on
here in fact hopefully the exercises to
this particular unit will make this a
little bit easier for you to see in
action but at any rate let me just make
a few asides over here the deeper asides
will be made in greater detail in our
supplementary notes notice that when we
dealt with differential calculus it was
very very important in differential
calculus to have smooth curves for
finding areas all you need are
continuous curves in other words for
example we can find the area of a square
but certainly a square has sharp corners
in other words those corners are
continuous but they're not
differentiable in terms of the language
of differential calculus the point is
that even continuity can be weakened let
me give you a definition here F is
called piecewise continuous on the
interval from A to B if and only
f is continuous except and a finite
number of points where it has jump
discontinuities for example in terms of
this particular diagram noticed that my
curve y equals f of X is discontinuous
at a finite number of points namely at
c1 and c2 two points notice that what
happens at those two points is you have
just a finite jump discontinuity the
point is that whereas this curve is not
continuous
notice that since a straight line having
no thickness has no area if we replace
the given curve by this one you see
putting in these real achill lines
notice that this does form a closed
region and to find the area of this
closed region I can pretend that was
made up of these three particular
regular regions in other words that even
if I just have jumps since the jump does
not contribute towards the area there is
no harm done when one talks about
piecewise continuous in finding areas
rather than continuous a second aside
where I've actually called this one
aside number one because it's definition
I didn't call on the side but the idea
is this notice that up until now we were
assuming that we had to form our U sub
ends and our L cévennes by choosing
either the left endpoint of a partition
or the right endpoint what I'd like you
to see also as a generalization is if I
pick any point between these two
extremes and form the I'll call it C sub
K between these two points here and form
this particular sum where C sub K
replaces either X sub K or X sub K minus
1 that this sum here also gives me the
area of the region R in other words that
whatever this sum is it's caught between
U sub N and L sub N and since u sub N
and L sub n have a common limit of a sub
r though since both of these squeezed in
towards a sub R this being caught
between them must also be a sub R that's
what I've said over here and to see this
thing in terms of a picture all we're
saying is that when you pick the lowest
point in the interval when you pick the
lowest point in the interval you get the
wreck
tangle that contributes to Elsa ban when
you pick the highest point in the
interval do you get the rectangle that
contributes to you sub M consequently
for any point between these two extremes
call that that's what C sub K is at any
point between these two pick the height
that corresponds to that and whatever
rectangle you form this way that
rectangle must have a greater area than
the rectangle that went into forming L
sub n but a lesser area than the
rectangle that went into forming U sub N
and consequently that's where this
particular result comes from again this
is done in more detail in the notes but
I think some of these things you should
hear me say out loud rather than to rely
on your reading it and finally one more
important point up until now it's been
clear that since we're talking about
area our region has to lie above the
x-axis we can remove the restriction
that s been non-negative if we replace
area by net area in other words all I
want you to see here is that if my
region happens to look something like
this
notice that between C and B f of X is
negative consequently when I form things
of the form f of X times Delta X Delta X
being positive f of X being negative is
going to give me a negative result in
other words algebraically if I form my
summation this portion in here will give
me a positive result this portion in
here will give me a negative result
consequently working algebraically what
I will find is not the true area but the
positive minus this amount here in other
words what I'll find is the net area and
again this will all be worked out in the
notes
in addition there'll be other
refinements made in the notes such as
that these partitions don't have to be
in two equal parts or things like this
the important point from today's lecture
is this observe that this entire study
of area is done independently of
differential calculus in our next
lecture we are going to show a truly
remarkable a wonderful relationship
between the differential calculus of
before and the so-called area or
integral calculus that we did today at
any rate until next time goodbye funding
for the publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and Paul
Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate